[Musique]
la parole autochtone les simili sa mort
lundi puis au lendemain de veille
électorale j'imagine que c'est la même
chose pour vous mon regard sur ces
élections qui n'ont pas changé grand
chose d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu
l'humour caustique que j'entends par
rapport au remaniement qui a coûté le
plus cher de toute l'histoire du canada
en plein tandis que vivre cependant j'ai
eu des transformations au niveau de
l'électorat est aussi d'aider des élus
autochtone alors je vous explique cette
année si bien sûr les dépouillements ne
sont pas contestés qu'on voit pas de
changement il y aura à nouveau onze élus
sont considérés autochtone dans à
travers tous les partis principaux c'est
que en 2015 justement c'est un avenir
record des élus et docks tonnes ça avait
diminué à 10 en 2019 et là on revient
aux nues ou chiffre 11 aujourd'hui en
2021 c'est quand même pas rien surtout
si on considère que la participation
d'élus autochtone ou de personnes en
élections sont considérées première
nation innu et/ou meti de l'ouest ont
vraiment augmenté de 62 à 70 7 c'est
vraiment une aiguille jab et on a
identifié quand même 24 circonscriptions
où le vote électoral le vote autochtone
peut vraiment faire basculer la donne
pour les parties donc
séduction par rapport à tout ce que
peuvent participer aux élections sont
d'origine autochtone cependant une
grande moins grande participation des
chefs de partis par exemple dans les
conversations dans les discours qui
concerne les prêts la nation surtout
après la découverte des corps des
enfants qui sont jamais revenus des
pensionnats de toute la mobilisation qui
est autour de 15 qui a donné on pensait
le jour du canada on se serait attendu à
beaucoup plus de disques aux beaucoup
plus de deux participations justement
des chefs de parti mais ça a été
beaucoup moindre et ça avait quand même
été
un plus pour les libéraux qui souhaitent
y lire pour justin trudeau d'ailleurs
qui avait été à l'époque que aucune
relation des plus importantes que sa
relation avec les communautés
autochtones du canada
ça avait augmenté d'ailleurs la
participation des membres des premières
nations ce avait permis de faire sortir
stephen harper qui était très
problématique dans ses relations avec
les communautés autochtones donc on
parlait d'une augmentation de 15 % du
vote autochtone c'est important mais
cette année on a senti que quand même le
creux vide les changements climatiques
sont venus de l'avant et probablement
ont pris la place dans la réflexion
électorale
des chefs de partis cependant la
discussion continue encore sur est ce
que je vois tout ce que je ne vote pas
dans des élections fédérales canadiennes
pour beaucoup de communautés autochtones
en corse c'est un gouvernement une forme
de gouvernance qu'on ne reconnaît pas
ces de la colonisation donc en votant
pour la colonisation est ce qu'on
accepte la colonisation c'est encore une
discussion qui a eu lieu
moi particulièrement je dis toujours je
vois malgré le fait que j'ai beaucoup
discuté à dire est ce que je vois pas ce
que j'ai accepté justement le canada
comme étant ma marraine et mon pays ou
est-ce que je vote parce que je prends
tous les moyens à ma disposition pour
pouvoir transformer le canada autour de
moi donc c'est encore de discussions qui
ont lieu d'ailleurs certaines
communautés je pense particulièrement à
six nations ont refusé ou non peuvent
vraiment mis beaucoup d'efforts pour que
des des sites pour voter soit présent
six nations ayant dit que si on
installait justement un lieu pour voter
ce serait une offense ou traité qui est
établi entre leur nation et sa
attaqueraient la souveraineté justement
daily nation qui sont présentes à ces
sessions alors super intéressant mais
vraiment un moment je dois dire clin
d'oeil dans l'histoire canadienne on
continue avec les enjeux qui nous touche
on essaye de faire entendre la parole
des communautés on espère vraiment que
la relation et les promesses de 2019
vont être enfin accompli dans ce monde
aussi on le souhaite en espérant que
vous vous regardez en santé mentale et
physique je vous souhaite une belle
semaine